okay
don't get me wrong i love dying glide
but it's time
for dying light too stop poking us
around
i want to play the dying light too when
would it be on sale
i want to play it right away
it's probably gonna have the same fate
as dead island 2
and never come out unfortunately
hello the england studio i hope
everything is doing okay but i'm really
worried about the game
i hope it's not canceled or something
what the [ __ ] do the [ __ ] dying
lights do
[ __ ] stop the dlcs
f word
release dying light 2 or give a [ __ ]
demo
god
ok everyone we got a message we
understand you are curious about the
game
because you want dying light 2 to be
good
as you have imagined and maybe you are
even a little
impatient because you have waited a long
time for
any news and updates this is a huge and
complex project
and we needed time to make sure it will
live up to our vision
all of us here are putting our hearts
into delivering a game
that you will keep playing for months
we'll be ready to start talking about
dying light too
very very soon the whole team needs your
trust and support
as this is what motivates us especially
now
when the circumstances are hard for
everyone we are proud of having such
devoted fans as you
no matter how you express your feelings
and just for you
here's a small snippet of what's coming
please
stay with us just a bit longer and stay
safe
thank you
[Music]
starting right now you can go to our
discord and find a special dl2 question
channel with a form that will let you
send questions directly to us to dev
team
we'll answer all of them in the form of
a series of short ask me anything movies